Guten Tag, ich heiße Dr. Korkmaz. Ich bin die Savender auf dieser Station. Ich würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ganz schilder Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Frank Schuster.
Frank Schuster.
Könnten Sie Ihre Nachname langsam bestabilten?
Ja, S-C-H-U-S-T-E-R.
Okay, Herr Schuster, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 6.08.1969.
69?
69.
Okay. Und Herr Schuster, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege jetzt 80 kg ungefähr.
Okay. Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 m.
Okay, Herr Schuster, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Mir geht es zurzeit überhaupt nicht gut. Ich habe immer solche Probleme beim Schlucken.
Und das wird in letzter Zeit immer schlimmer.
Das hat angefangen, da vorm Vierteljahr, würde ich sagen, so im Frühjahr, habe ich das das erste Mal gemerkt.
Und das wird aber immer mehr. Am Anfang war das so, dass ich das vor allen Dingen hatte, wenn ich schnell gegessen habe.
Oder wenn ich so Sachen hatte, die ziemlich trockene sind, wenn ich also nur ein Brot gegessen habe.
Dann hatte ich manchmal so das Gefühl, ich kriege das gar nicht richtig runter.
Und jetzt ist es aber so, dass auch wenn ich wirklich sehr gründlich kauhe, dass das richtig unangenehm ist beim Schlucken.
Und selbst beim Trinken tut mir das weh. Und das war früher überhaupt nicht.
Entschuldigung, wann? Sie haben gesagt vor vier Monaten.
Ja, so eng als wir.
Ja, okay. Erst mal unsere Beschwerden angefangen.
Da ist mir das das erste Mal so richtig aufgefallen.
Und die Schluckprobleme hat langsam begonnen.
Ja, und am Anfang denkt man sich ja nichts Böses, da denkt man, das ist immer nicht gut gekaut und so.
Aber das wird immer schlimmer.
Und jetzt habe ich halt langsam so dieses Gefühl, dass mir das Essen und Schlucken wirklich schwer fällt.
Und ich habe jetzt auch mit einmal immer so so brennen.
Das ist ja ganz unangenehm.
Seit wann haben Sie so brennen?
Ich würde vielleicht sagen, seit vier Wochen, fünf Wochen.
Und Husten ist auch so dazugekommen.
Das ist mir nicht mehr so richtig gut geht.
Leiden Sie auch unter Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen? Ja, also beim Schlucken tut das manchmal auch noch hier so oben in der Brust ein bisschen weh.
Bei Schlucken, aber nur?
Nur beim Schlucken, ja.
Okay, möchtet ihr noch etwas hinzufedern?
Ich meine, gibt es noch mehr Beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe überhaupt keinen Appetit zur Zeit.
Und nachts kann ich nicht schlafen.
Ich habe das Henkfett auch mit dem Sozut brennen zusammen.
Und ich habe mir jetzt schon extra Kissen noch mal ins Bett getan.
Aber da rutscht man ja auch irgendwann runter.
Und dann schenkt es doch wieder an.
Also ich habe dann manchmal abends ein Schnaps getrunken, damit das mit dem Hals besser wird.
Aber das hat auch nichts geholfen.
Und ja, also das ist alles, ich fühle mich einfach schlecht jetzt.
Ja, Sie fühlen auch Müdigkeit oder?
Ja, so bisschen schlapp bin ich aufgeworfen.
Ja, aber ich denke immer, das hängt damit zusammen, dass ich so wenig Appetit habe und dass ich auch so schlecht schlafe.
Das waren natürlich Müde.
Und haben Sie in der Lester abgenommen?
Ja, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Ja, ich habe eigentlich ziemlich viel abgenommen sogar.
Ich hatte mal ordentlich mehr Gewicht, ich hatte 89 kg.
Und jetzt wiege ich nur noch 80 kg.
Das fand ich eigentlich am Anfang ganz nett.
Aber das finde ich langsam nicht mehr so witzig.
Diese vier Monate haben Sie?
Ja, ich denke so.
Nachdem habe ich mich mal gewogen oder im neuen Jahr dann.
Und jetzt ist mir das aufgefallen, dass die Hosen alle so weit sind, habe ich mich mal wieder gewogen, mache ich nicht so oft.
Fühlen Sie sich auch fieberig?
Fieberig fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Sie leiden an Hustern.
Dieser Hustern ist trockener oder auswürfener?
Nein, da kommt so Schleim mit.
Mit Schleim.
Wie sieht diese Schleim aus?
Also ich würde sagen, das ist so weissliches Zeug, so durchsichtiger Schleim.
Weiß ich.
Okay.
Und die Schmerzen, ich möchte ein bisschen darüber sprechen.
Die Schmerzen strahlen irgendwo hin aus?
Die Schmerzen sind vor allem im Halsbereich.
Da habe ich manchmal das Gefühl, dass ich gegen einen Widerstand anschlucke.
Und dann eben hier im oberen Brustbereich, direkt hinter dem Brustbein, dass ich das Gefühl habe, da drückt es beim Schlucken.
Wie könnten Sie beschreiben diese Schmerzen?
Drückend.
Manchmal auch, wenn ich die Soht brennen habe, natürlich auch brennend.
Brennend und drückend.
Okay, Herr Schuster.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche Beurkrankungen?
Ich meine Bluthochdruck oder Blutsucker?
Ja, Bluthochdruck, das hat man vor 15 Jahren testgestellt, dass ich ein bisschen Blutschhochdruck habe.
Vor 15 Jahren.
15?
Okay.
Und da nehme ich Methoprololein, das ist so ein Beta-Blocker.
Und das soll helfen.
Wissen Sie in welcher Dosierung?
Ja, ich nehme da morgens eine und da steht Methoprolol 95 drauf.
Und dann nehme ich noch aspirin, 100, jeden Tag.
Und ich hatte mal vor, wie lange ist das jetzt her, so vier, fünf Jahren, hatte ich eine Windhombose und hatte auch eine Lungenembolie.
Und da war ich damals im Krankenhaus.
Und danach nehme ich dann jetzt seit dreieinhalb Jahren nämlich aspirin regelmäßig ein.
Ich entschuldige, ich möchte sicher so sein, wir haben Wendantrombos seit vier Jahren, oder?
Vor vier Jahren.
Und Krampfadern habe ich schon länger.
Und seit dieser Thrombose bin ich auch ganz brav und trage meine Kompressionstrumpfen.
Okay.
Und noch etwas?
Ja, aber das reichen wir auch völlig.
Ja, natürlich.
Herr Schutter, ich möchte nur wissen, würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nee, operiert bin ich überhaupt noch nie.
Okay.
Und Sie nehmen regelmäßig Methoprolol und aspirin ein, gibt es noch etwas?
Nö, sonst nehme ich keine Tabletten.
Und sind Sie vollständig gegen Corona?
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Okay.
Herr Schuster, ist Ihnen irgendwelche Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nein, ich wüsste nicht, dass irgendwas ist, was jemals festgestellt wurde.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich jemals allergische Reaktionen hatte.
Ich kann auch alles essen.
Okay, gut.
Und Herr Schuster, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche schon kräftig, ja.
Seit wann und wie viel?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen.
Ich bin jetzt 54, dann rauche ich seit mehr als 30 Jahren.
Und so ein halb Päckchen am Tag gehen das schon durch.
Einundhalb.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ein paar Flaschen Bier am Abend trinke ich wohl.
Und wenn wir Karten spielen, dann trinken wir auch mal Schnaps dazu.
Oder auch wenn es gutes Essen gab.
Also ein paar Mal in der Woche gibt es auch noch ein bisschen Schnaps dazu.
Am Wochenende schlopst du.
Nein, auch wenn ich Karten spielen gehe, dann sind wir bei Dienstags.
Da trinken wir auch immer einen dazu.
Ja, Sie meinen einmal pro Woche.
Nee, eher zweimal pro Woche.
Okay, nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nee, mit Drogen habe ich keinen Kontakt.
Herr Schuster, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Angestellter bei der Handwerkskammer.
Okay, leiden Sie an Stress bei der Arbeit?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Oder bei Ihrer Privatlevel?
Ja, also ich bin geschieden.
Das war mal eine stressige Zeit, aber jetzt bin ich halt alleine
und bin auf ganz gut klar.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind schon groß.
Okay, sind Sie oder Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund beide, ja.
Ja, das war eine Kinder, okay.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall
und der war auch herzkrank.
Das ist noch nicht lange her, dass er verstorben ist.
Meine Mutter ist eigentlich ganz gut beieinander.
Die hat nur, genauso wie ich, die Krampfadern an den Beinen
und hat damit so ein bisschen zu tun.
Ja, dann hat man jetzt bei ihr so ein Altersdiabetes festgestellt.
Aber sonst ist sie eigentlich noch ganz gut beieinander.
Und wie war unsere Geschwister?
Ich hatte einen Bruder, der hatte eine blöde Krebserkrankung,
der hatte so ein Krebs in der Bauchspeicheldrüse
und der ist ganz schnell verstorben da dran.
Es looked mir sehr light.
Okay, Herr Schuster, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufinden oder fragen?
Ja, ich mache mir natürlich jetzt Sorgen,
was das ist mit meinem Hals.
Und ich möchte natürlich auch irgendwann mal wieder
ohne Beschwerden essen.
Dass es mir so schlecht geht,
macht mir natürlich auch ein bisschen Gedanken.
Was kann man denn jetzt tun?
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, Herr Schuster.
Aber es ist so für dich, um zu diagnostikieren,
ich muss erstmal ein paar Bildgewändes verfahren,
durchführen und natürlich...
Was heißt das?
Ja, wie Spiegelung,
Speiser Röhrle Spiegelung.
Das klingt aber sehr unangenehm.
Ist das sehr schmerzhaft?
Ja, es klingt ein bisschen unangenehm,
aber Sie bekommen eine Schlafmitteil.
Deswegen füllen Sie sich...
Merk ich das alles?
Ja, gar nicht.
Dann ist gut, dann können Sie irgendwas mit mir anstellen.
Ja, machen wir das jetzt gleich?
Oder muss man dafür ins Krankenhaus kommen?
Richtig, nicht da einen späteren Termin.
Ich muss mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen erstmal
und vielleicht können wir heute dürfen können.
Das wäre ja praktisch, da muss ich nicht nochmal extra kommen.
Ja, ich muss aber erstmal meinen Oberarzt sprechen.
Okay.
Was machen Sie? Was kann man denn dagegen machen?
Ja, ich habe schon gesagt, es ist so für uns zu diagnostikieren,
je nach den Ergebnissen sprechen wir wieder.
Aber ich vermute, es gibt eine Spiegelröhre Probleme,
aber ich bin natürlich nicht sicher.
Deswegen muss ich erstmal diese Verfahren durchwöhnen.
Ah, okay, das verstehe ich.
Ja, gut.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Bemerkten Sie die Farbeveränderungen Ihres Schulz?
Das habe ich akustisch nicht verstanden.
Können Sie das bitte noch einmal sagen?
Könnten Sie die Farbeveränderungen Ihres Schulz?
Farbeveränderungen?
Ja, eine Farbveränderung im Stuhl ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Schülern Sie, als ob eine große Menge an Schweichherl im Mund vorhanden wäre?
Das habe ich manchmal, ja.
Aber nicht ständig.
Ja, okay, genau.
Können Sie vermehrt jetzt Nachtschweiß?
Ja, zurzeit ist es halt warm, da schwitzt man nachts mal, aber das würde ich jetzt nicht...
Ja, ich meine, brauchen Sie Ihre Kleidung wegsehen?
Manchmal muss ich nachts jetzt, wenn es so warm ist,
es ist warm in meiner Wohnung und dann muss ich nachts mal den Schlafanzug ausziehen
und frischen anziehen, aber nicht regelmäßig, nur jetzt, wo es so warm ist.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Eigentlich so richtig übel ist mir nicht.
Ich merke halt, dass mir das Essen schwer fällt und das kann man so schwer unterscheiden von Übelkeit.
Ich sitze halt dann vor dem Essen und habe keine Lust, das zu essen,
weil ich weiß, es wird alles so mühsam und das ist dann...
und dann weiß ich ja auch, dass das so brennen irgendwann kommt
und dann mag man schon nicht mehr.
Mussten Sie nicht...
Nein, bitte, nicht sprechen.
Okay, andere?
Leiden Sie unter Heiserkeit?
Heiserkeit, ja.
Eigentlich bisher nicht, nein.
Haben Sie endische Beschwerden gehabt?
Früher mal?
Ne, das habe ich noch nie gehabt, solche Beschwerden.
Waren Sie wegen dieser Beschwerde beim anderen als gewesen?
Nein, ich gehe nicht so gerne zum Arzt.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerzgala von 1 bis 10, vorbei 1 sehr leicht,
10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht.
Also, wenn ich Flüssigkeiten schlucke,
dann sind das so leichte Schmerzen,
das ist dann vielleicht so 3 oder 4,
aber wenn ich feste Sachen runter schlucke,
oder auch wenn ich aus Versehen zu schnell esse
und ich sehr gut gekauert habe,
oder den Mund zu voll hatte,
und dann schlucke, dann sind das schon heftige Schmerzen,
dann sind die zwischen 6 und 7.
Danke schön.
Ist Ihnen irgendwelche Schwelungen im Halsbereich aufgefallen?
Ich meine wie Lünknoten oder so?
Da kenne ich mich nicht mit aus, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, danke.
Am Ende eine Frage, Aufstoßen, haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, er hat ja gesagt, Sud brennen, das ist so ähnlich.
Das ist ja so saures Aufstoßen.
Ja, doch das hat er schon.
Danke schön.
Blutaberechen, keine.
Bitte was?
Eine Kollegin hat geçen, eine Blutaberechen.
Blutaberechen, eine, ist nicht, ist nicht.
Die Patriot hat gesagt, keine Blutaberechen,
manchmal eine Bomythinchen, eine Neusea, oder.
Okay, ich denke alle Fragen sind gestartet.
Können wir erst als Gechübren anfangen?
Ja, ich würde so sagen.
Okay.
Guten Tag, mein Oberarztin.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen, haben Sie dafür kurz gesagt?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie haben Sie denn gesehen?
Frank Schuster ist 54-Jährige Patient.
Er kam heute wegen, seit vier Monaten bestehende
drückende Schluckschmerzen zu uns.
Wo hat er die Schmerzen?
Im Halsbereich.
Und die Schmerzen haben langsam begonnen.
Erstmal gegen festes Lebensmittel.
Und danach gegen die Physikkeit.
Können Sie mir da auch Kraftbegriffen nennen?
Dußfalsche.
Dußfalsche, ja.
Seit vier bis fünf Wochen klagt der Patient
über Pyrosis-Husten auch die Schmerzen.
Lege bei Physikkeit auf einer Schmerzschikare
bei drei bis vier.
Und bei festes Lebensmittel bei sechs bis sieben.
Und als relativ anamnese leidet der Patient in Appetanz
insomnia-Patik und Gebietsverlohren.
Er hat Neun Kilo innerhalb vier Monaten abgenommen.
Auch nackscheweis.
Er klagt über nackscheweis.
An vorerkrankungen leidet ein arterielles Hypertonie seit 13 Jahren.
Der Patient leidet nicht an nackscheweis.
Manchmal.
Wenn das Wetter warm ist.
Also er hat das nicht als typische Symptome.
Okay.
Nackscheweis, keine nackscheweis.
An vorerkrankungen leidet er an arterielles Hypertonie seit 15 Jahren.
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, seit wann.
Und vor vier Jahren hatte er Lungenembolie.
Er nimmt regelmäßig Metaprolol morgens und aspirin 100 mg.
Er ist geimpft, vollständig geimpft.
Er hat keine Allergie und keine Unverträglichkeit.
Seit 30 Jahren raucht er täglich ein und halbe Pakosigaret.
Er trinkt ein Fläscherbier täglich und soweit bis dreimal pro Woche Schnaps.
Er ist angestellter, er ist geschieden, hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Sein Vater ist an Apoplexie gestorben.
Sein Bruder ist an Pancrasia aufgestorben.
Seine Mutter leidet an Varissen und Diabetes Melidius.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Ösophagus carcinum.
Als Differenzialdiagnose denke ich Akalasia, Ulcus ventruchuli und Magna carcinum.
Ich werde erstmal körperliche Untersuchungen.
Die Lampfknoten im Achselhöhle und im Halsbereich kontrollieren.
Was machen Sie?
Es gibt Schwellungen im Halsbereich.
Sie schauen nach dem Allgemeinen Zustand.
Was machen Sie?
Ich habe eine Blutbild, CRP, BZG, NIRM und Weboparameter kontrolliert.
Ich habe Ösophagus-Diodoskopie geplant.
Ich habe eine Ultraschalldürfel.
Ich habe eine Cardiac-Enzyme.
Der Patient hat 54 Jahre alt.
Es gibt Risikofaktoren, Familiare, Brauchersch und Alkoholiker.
Deshalb müssen wir diese Patientin auf jeden Fall eine Feldach-Akutes-Corner-Sendung denken.
Und dann erstmal Cardiac-Enzyme bestimmen.
Wenn Sie sich Ihre Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen,
was würde man dann diagnostisch noch auf alle Fälle weitermachen?
Komftelthermografie, Kopfabdomen und Torax.
Um herauszufinden, ob da irgendwas schon gestreut hat.
Was wäre eine Therapieoption?
Ich fahre eine schulische Konzil an.
Ich bin gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Halten Sie mich bitte auf den laufenden.
Das war relativ vollständig.
Bei der Anamnese hatten viele Kollegen noch zusätzliche Fragen.
Da ist mir nur eine Sache aufgefallen.
Als der Patient gefragt hat, was ist denn da jetzt?
Was kann man dagegen tun?
Da haben Sie irgendwie diagnostizieren.
Das ist ein sehr blödsinniges Wort.
Was Sie nicht genau übermittelt haben, ist die Alkoholmenge.
Der hat das ja so ein bisschen bagatellisiert.
Der trinkt jeden Tag nicht nur eine Flaschenbier, sondern einige Flaschenbier.
Er trinkt regelmäßig Schnaps.
Zwei Mal in der Woche am Wochenende und dann wenn er zum Kart spielen geht.
Das ist schon zweimal in der Woche.
Er sagt auch nicht dazu, wie viel Schnaps er trinkt.
Er hat in Lauchenseines Lebens schon einiges an Gift-Intos.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man in einem Fall nachfragen würde.
Wenn es dem im Augenblick schlecht geht, ob er jetzt immer noch raucht.
Und ob er immer noch Schnaps trinkt.
Er hat gesagt, dass er gegen das Sodbrennen Schnaps getrunken hat.
Das ist natürlich nicht das Mittel der Wahl.
Aber viele Leute haben das Gefühl, diese berühmte Verdauungsschnaps.
Irgendwie so ein Kräuterzeug oder so etwas,
das dann angeblich hilft, irgendwas zu verdauen.
Und da das besser rutscht.
Das erbt es natürlich auch mal hinterher.
Ja, beim Bericht.
Wie gesagt, Anamnese war nur diese eine Geschichte besprachlich nicht so richtig.
Und gefragt haben sie konsequent, würde ich sagen.
Eigentlich haben sie sprachlich auch nicht so viele Schwierigkeiten
in der Verständigung und konnten auch gut auf den Patienten eingehen.
Wo sie nochmal gucken müssen.
Ich habe das schon im letzten Mal wirklich auch nicht so richtig drauf geachtet.
Aber Dr. Gündis hat zum Glück darauf hingewiesen,
gucken Sie, dass sie, wie ich die Fachbegriffe verwenden.
Wenn sie das Arztgespräch haben.
Also, Varicosis, was sie auch nicht gesagt haben,
er hat angegeben, dass er Kompressionsstrumpfe trägt.
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, sie haben nicht gefragt,
wie lange er schon die Krampfadern hat.
Aber er hatte ja vor vier Jahren eine Lungenembolie und der TVT.
Also hatte er da auf alle Fälle schon Varizen.
Und wahrscheinlich trägt er seitdem die Schrünfe, kann man von ausgehen.
Wenigstens seitdem.
Das ist vielleicht noch so eine Geschichte, die man noch erwähnen könnte.
Und das macht dann eben auch logisch, dass er das aspirin nimmt.
Dass er die Thrombose hinter sich hatte.
Ja, und sonst habe ich eigentlich keine weiteren Ergänzungen oder Anmerkungen.
Das klingt alles vernünftig.
Danke.
Okay.